[Music]
foreign
can you describe a little bit about sort
of what was going on in your
neighborhood or like how you how you
started to kind of get involved with the
kind of life that led you into to being
incarcerated and what that was about
sure yeah um it's kind of funny because
I feel like
it's cliche to say well you know I lived
in it and it was all about it and this
and that and I feel like that's not
wrong but it's not right it's not wrong
because yeah I grew up in it and you you
just navigated through it and I I didn't
really understand it until like
trauma you know like more trauma outside
trauma and to be fair we took the loss
of my father to meet like and then like
a veil dropped I realized like so many
things the writing on the wall the
literal writing on the wall the spray
painting of the names you know I always
use references to my dad's friends you
know it's like one of them is his name
was Crow you know and I'm like as a kid
before I knew when I was still a little
kid and all these dudes used to be at my
grandma's house on my with my dad and my
uncles and then I just thought they were
guys you know and cool guys you know oh
this is my uncle this is that I didn't
realize the tattoos meant something I
didn't realize that tattoos were like
different I didn't realize that these
dudes were like you know drug addicts or
you know murderers you know and and once
that happened it dropped and then you
know you realize like I've been here in
my whole [__] life you know how did
so so how did losing your dad how how
did the veil drop like how did how did
that Discovery happen I I don't I feel
like it was just like a matter of like
now I just saw with my heart you know I
saw with my instead of with my mind and
when my eyes you know I saw with the
heart that I had which was and beat up
by then it was like a little mauled and
bruised and then I realized it and I saw
the ugly of what the ugly is in the
neighborhood you know the [__] dude
in the corner that's like just strung
out before I saw him but then I'd be
like oh that's you know that's Jay man I
know Jay he's been there for [__]
ever man just you know just be careful
sometimes he's like he's a little crazy
he might get up and start swinging but
he's Jay man he's in the corner right
that's all you know like then I like oh
Jay is [__] heroin at it he's [__]
gone like Jay's been gone you know he's
never been here he's the finality of
like losing your dad or seeing the
circumstances I like how these things
now all of a sudden these things took on
a different everything was resonance and
then Crow was not longer like like I
said before that I go [__] man I wish my
mom named me Crow that's a badass
[__] name I didn't realize that was a
nickname you know I I nicknames to me
were like meme or or you know like or or
Sito you know someone used to call me
Sito you know for little Jose you know
but those are nicknames I didn't know
that Crow frog you know like all these
gang names you know were like oh [__]
you know and then then you saw frog for
who he was a [__] bully you
know like he was like before Oh that's
frog he always gives me a dollar man or
that's probably he always gives me he
buys me a bag of chips if he sees me at
the store but then you realize dude I
saw a frog beating the living [__] out
of some dude and taking his because he
owed him money in the in the alley man
like holy [__] I didn't know that was
frog you know like yeah now you now I
knew who frog was now I knew don't [__]
with frog you know like you know before
I didn't I had no like that fear that
that understand I would just walk
through the streets and I would just
walk because I didn't get it until that
happened I saw the streets for what they
were you know that I was living in a
neighborhood I was living in in this
area where there's [__] monsters you
know and there was prey and there was
predators and even the prey were
predators somewhere else you know it was
just a matter of like you know how you
saw it and then
all that sticking to the corner alarm's
length when I just tell you about my now
it [__] kicked in you know and then
like that's what I mean it the veil
dropped now I'm like at arm's length
from J because now I know you know you
can probably hurt me you know even
though before he wasn't because maybe I
was just nonchalantly walking by him and
he was just like you know how you see a
lion and some little [__] lizard
walks by and he's just like
you know whatevers but now there's
lizard's walking closer got a little
bigger now the lion might [__] slap
that [__] you know so that's when I
realized things like that and then on
top of that my pain and my loss like
not only that was like a like a jigsaw
piece to the rest of the guys there you
know my other kids like me maybe not the
same but the same oh he don't have a mom
he don't have a dad oh well he's almost
like you you know so it's like yeah and
we have the same thing hey who's calling
you like hey you know you got to go home
you know it's like eight and nine nine
at night no not really no one's calling
me you know because before I used to be
like I'll say you know like somebody
calling you come home you know the
[__] street lights are on you know we
used to be playing ball soccer you know
before the veil dropped now you know
it's like the ones they're calling you
no one's really tripping on you yo you
can kick it okay yeah I'll kick it yeah
I'll kick it with you for like and then
it's like I don't want to go home me
neither and then that becomes that
adhesive like you were saying that that
those bonds that becomes the love that
you know and that and then everything is
flipped family becomes them you know
good becomes bad yellow becomes green
you know you know so everything becomes
opposite you know and so from that and
then the obviously the the the whatever
teenager goes you know your your friends
are your biggest influence this is that
an extreme dream because now you have
someone like casually like sliding you a
gun like hey you you're paying you have
some pain you know I'll tell you how you
could release some of that pain you know
here you go you know like in some not
literal but in a literal sense like here
you go man you know get some power back
you know and so here you are and then
you have this pain this extreme pain you
have another person people and a group
of people you know and they just have
this [__] pain you know this loss
this this whatever you know and then you
know [__] up dreams you know we have
dreams but they're [__] warped now
you know they're they're different you
know We're Dreaming smaller before
you're a dream big you know like [__]
yeah you know now you're just dreaming
like [__] yeah I'm just gonna come up
you know I want a car you know like
something small We're Dreaming small you
know and then you have someone who's
smarter manipulating you you know hey
man you just want a car cool man I could
use you and I'll get 70 cars I'll give
you a car but I'll use your ass for the
69 you know because I could I could see
that you're gullible you know I could
see that I could use you you know so
then you have to navigate those dudes
right because then you start to hear
wait a minute man you know what nah I
know what you're trying to do you know
but you can't Buck back because you're
still a little
fish you know so you're like okay just a
matter of like either you Buck back
stick in the wind another [__] time
or stay in the corner and try to survive
or you try to [__] be like whoop
whoop you know like okay you know what
I'm just gonna avoid that guy you know
because at the end of the day I know
what he's trying to do he's trying to
recruit me or he's trying to hurt me or
he's trying to take from me you know
and so yeah that's what I feel like I
always equate that you know once that
happened like everything just went that
Veil that veil was dropped and you
clearly had I mean you had a familiarity
and a cogency at that point with with
with violence because there was violence
in your own home in that Sacred Space
um love was warped that love was warped
love came with the slap so it's like
even and and it fit perfectly because
out there when we what we we were
together in the shittiest places and the
shittiest times me I mean we as in my
friends my same age maybe a little bit
older
um and sometimes we buck heads you know
I'm like what you know you know we'd
fight each other beat each other up and
then be like hey man you know
you know what you know why I did that
right you know you know you know we we
disagreed but you know what you know
we're cool you know the bond is Solider
now because even though you [__] beat
me up or I beat you up like that's how I
know love because I love you like that
you know with that love can you just
talk about sort of like your first
encounters with with with
I'm very I'm fascinated by the the link
of uh of those two emotions of of
violence and love I mean I I often
it said with me you know my closest
friends that that I made in my life were
the guys that I grew up with and and
they were the guys that we got in street
fights with there were guys we played
football with and there's that there's
the there's a there's a um currency
there
where if it's not just that you rough
ass with each other that you fight each
other but it's like hey these guys it's
us against them and the way to express
my love to you is to really be down for
you and to be there for you can you talk
about your first real experiences with
that your first real experiences with
violence and and that that you saw
outside of the house oh man yeah every
day you come out and you see someone
whose friends beating the [__] out of
each other but then I feel like
even though there was more experience
then I think it was better I think it'd
be better to me to say as an example is
when I went to prison because when I
went to prison like in the unit that we
were in like the the you know we beat
each other or we check each other with
violence and then we would always tell
each other like you know what that's
homie love you know like like I love you
man but you got a little bit out of line
you know and and you like bleeding out
you're like oh thanks you know like but
but it's also like
that also solidified for me the fear of
of like realizing that I had a bigger
fear of disappointing than a than a fear
of dying meaning like I would rather go
and get my ass kicked by 50 dudes by
myself then to get my ass kicked by my
one friend who I loved a lot and I rest
themed a lot or maybe an older homie who
I loved in estimate which might happen
but like I'd rather them beating the
living snot out of me then I disappoint
that dude or them not show up for me not
show up for them and then they hit me
and then they [__] do that to me you
know because then if they're gone I have
nobody do you remember your first sort
of interactions with law enforcement and
your feelings towards law enforcement
the first interaction I had with police
officer I think I was in kindergarten
and they would come to kindergarten with
their [__] car and like their cops
man they're [__] they look like look
Heroes you know they're [__] handsome
dudes you know like [__] with their
with their uniform all shiny you know in
their [__] car pull up and they have
a dog and they have this gun and they're
like you know this and you're just like
[__] yeah you know this is the [__]
shh the White Knight that flies in and
[__] clears a path but then
one thing is they never come back
like I said the continuous theme you
know and when they did come back it was
different the the next interactions I
had with them they were breaking down my
door and they were coming after my dad
because someone called the cops because
he was beating the [__] out of my mom
and it was just [__] loud you know
and he they came and they cuffed them up
and it was just more of like how old
were you then do you remember man
maybe after kindergarten maybe like
first second and so and did you did you
draw that in your head that that same
like did it Dawn on you those same
people that came into your kindergarten
class those Heroes those people that
were so clean and handsome it did it did
but they were they were they were like
your parents when they were not in their
best like they weren't that they were
like your parents with disheveled hair
or or smelling like [__] because they
haven't showered or you know so which
happens you know like because it's
normal but now they were that there was
like a mar there was there was a smidge
of dirt on that on that that Sheen that
they had you know and then they would
not they looked at me differently
because no longer were they looking at
you they were looking through you you
know like like like a [__] Terminator
you know
foreign
[Music]